le cobalt est dans la phase organique il
est devenu bleu al ça va prendre un peu
de temps à seéparer comme comme l'huile
et le vinaigre mais c'est le même
principe pour la la séparation cobalt
nickel ou lithium ce sont les composants
issus des batteries de voiture
électrique amené à être recyclé et c'est
ici dans ce centre de recherche à trappe
que seront testé et validé les premières
étapes du recyclage il y a une
quarantaine de collaborateurs qui vont
travailler dans cette usine pilote
essentiellement des ingénieurs et des
techniciens nous allons en recruter
d'ailleurs de nouveau pour pouvoir
travailler dans cette cette usine pilote
et donc pour pouvoir tester ce procédé
qui sera après développé de façon
industrielle définitive dans une usine à
dunkererc pour sa construction le site
de 800 m² a nécessité un investissement
de 10 millions d'euros dont deux de
subvention l'usine pilote représente un
projet phare pour le gouvernement qui
vise à long terme l'indépendance
énergétique l'enjeu c'est planification
écologique et la manière dont nous
allons développer des solutions de
mobilité électrique sur le territoire
des solutions qui soient à la portée des
Français et qui permettent aussi de
créer des emplois en France de créer de
la richesse en France et de
réindustrialiser notre pays l'usine se
donne 2 ans pour réaliser les tests
avant de lancer la phase industrielle à
d'unkererc